boom i'm going with it i'm going with
you
because i can't deal with any of this
yeah yeah yeah deal with this pressure
yeah yeah yeah bro
i've got to deal with this pressure
[Music]
mission um mission 1kg
you guys already know what i'm going to
say but for the newbies
for the newbies there's always newbies
remember when there never used to be
newbies
well nobody now but when you are nobody
nobody
wow struggle um yeah for the newbies
mission 1k so if you like the episodes
now
and you want more we'll double up two a
week as soon as we get to
a thousand pounds on patreon
we're moving and shaking so thank you to
all the new patrons as always
uh but yeah links in the description
links on the instagram links on the
twitter everything you need
uh links are about and um yeah man sign
up today three pound a month tempe your
day run in my pee
you get me and um
yeah g any urgent biz have you ever
like actually i don't know have you ever
gone to a hotel
do your thing
go hotel have you ever gone to a hotel
or like
struggled with somewhere that has [ __ ]
internet
and you try and watch porn it's the
most frustrating experience
ever like there are times when i go back
to my mom's my mom has [ __ ] internet
my mom my mum is the type of person that
doesn't really notice it because
she's not a streamer as long as her
phone works that she can watch youtube
my mum is like that's my mom my mom is
live she doesn't give a [ __ ] that's my
mom so all these netflix on these
streaming stuff
that's mine youtube obviously is is
streaming but it's not it doesn't take
up as much as all these other ones yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so i remember
specifically everyone used to go home a
bit more frequently last year
this is before my mom changed up the
internet i'd always have to
either hotspot my phone to my laptop or
watch it
4g on my phone and i'm like
this is 20 20. my phone doesn't let me
watch it 4g
my phone says no i mean it's it's so
frustrating
it makes me want to call my mom and be
like you need to sort your instant out
because i can't watch porn
and obviously i shouldn't even that
shouldn't even be a conversation yeah
bro do you know what i mean
so jarring bro buffering porn is the
most jarring thing
when we first moved to coventry for uni
[Music]
in calais they offered you free internet
i remember and it was the shittiest
internet and i think it was a hundred
pound for the year
for the premium thing at that time i
didn't have a hundred pounds so
i just had to do the free thing the
worst internet [ __ ] possibly
imaginable i remember and i remember
freshers week i had to load up my pawn
and let it buffer go on a night out
because i knew i wasn't sure on [ __ ] i
knew i wasn't secure in [ __ ] so i had
to go on a night out and i'd know
that's my vid for the next three days
whether it bangs or not
that's gonna have to be my vid for the
next three days i did that in priory
because did you
probably have the same thing the basic
internet and the premiums
i got the premium but the premium wasn't
normal fluidity that is like nowadays 20
20. it still buffed a little bit so i
did the same thing i opened
tabs i opened tabs i later just run
came back and then i selected what i was
going to use i did the same
when we moved into grafton you know i
think i moved in first you did
because i did some little job thing yeah
that door-to-door job one of the worst
things i've ever done
i was i was i was a little salesman for
like two weeks i quit
but the funny thing's dead man made pee
i mean i couldn't fathom it
i couldn't fathom it oh bro i remember
you said so
i i think our internet was our internet
was
either it was very slow because we did
have internet but which is very very
very slow
so i loaded up for time time and
obviously i was living by myself
at that time because none of you might
have moved in yet yeah yeah i was just
all i did digging down was wank wank
and i remember i was i was with i had a
girlfriend at the time
and when she had come back to uni i
remember her asking me
why has your dick gotten bigger do you
know what i mean because
i i must have been obviously i didn't
realize but i must have been
fapping bro working out those muscles
working out those muscles
bro buffering porn is buffering porn is
the [ __ ]
dead deadest thing it kills the whole
move oh it's so
annoying and it just makes you when
you're watching porn you don't want to
be
aware of how much of a sleaze bag you
are of course so when you're having to
buffer it
and you're waiting and waiting you're
just like [ __ ] hands you can hand you
just like what the [ __ ] am i doing
cause i'm sick of this
and i'm actually i can't believe i was
so certain now now i'm thinking back
about the commentary now i can't believe
i was so certain that i wasn't gonna get
[ __ ] on my night out
that i had to buffer up porn that's
jokes i don't know i've never known that
no no i've never known that that's
hilarious and the only reason
i did it is because i had to hang out
with some white guys the first week
okay so the first week in general uni so
basically
what happened was story time i moved in
so this is before i even met you so i
think i was there
i must have been there four or five days
before our first
lecture okay so maybe even longer
and i knew i was there for a significant
period of time before lecture started
i know that for a fact so before i met
you before i remember before i met
anyone
i just met jess and the other people in
my yeah
yes yes so i knew nobody we've already
gone through the ordeal of how i didn't
want to meet people
so i knew no one so i've established my
internet [ __ ]
and i've pretty much just locked it off
um and then
jess was going on a night out and said
do you want to come
um i've met some people um do you want
to hang out with us tonight and come out
with us i was like
not really but i have no one else and
nothing else to do
the internet [ __ ] and back then netflix
didn't exist
[ __ ] we're old netflix didn't exist they
were still doing that delivery
the dvd for the letterbox that's what
they were doing [ __ ] so it didn't exist
so i didn't even have netflix to watch
millennials don't even know about that
bro the young folk won't even understand
why
blockbuster blockbuster woolworths
pick a mix oh sorry
sorry tangents galore sorry so she asked
me to go out with these man and i was
like
you know you already know if you know me
this is my nightmare
this is my nightmare going out with a
girl that i barely know
with people i don't know i already know
this and i was just like ah so i'll get
up there
and guess who was one of them one of the
guys
one of the people that jess was with
demetrius
no saucy no no no go
um
manche no way gemma manchu was one of
them no way
yeah yeah now i'm thinking connecting
dots and all that stuff is weirder
that's actually
she probably won't even remember this
but that's actually the first time that
i ever met her
okay was like our second or third day in
kov
i knew no one i went up with jess to
because they were living in callus as
well okay so we just went to their block
um met them at them so it was it was
jess
it was gemma maybe one other girl that i
can't remember
and two guys the two
guys uh two white guys that j uh that
manchester knew
um from cambridge or wherever she's from
possessed [ __ ] guys i've ever met
posies [ __ ] guys i've ever met yeah
so they're like oh cool let's go out
so we roll out and then one of the dons
turns to me
and it's like ah have you found out how
slow the internet is
and i was like it's unbearable and he
was like bro
i've been trying to watch porn and i
can't so i'll just have to leave it to
buffer something but so we can go out
light bulb light bulb i was like oh my
god
savior i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do
that so i did that the next this is one
of the cambria studies one of the
cambridge johnnies
so i was like gang gang man hooked you
up
and then um the reasons i stopped
hanging out with him i think i've told
you the story before the reason i
started hanging out with him because i
went out with that night
bearing him on his peak because
obviously these are rich
cambridge donnies they had squirrels so
on these nights out i had about 11 pound
costs
for the international [ __ ] that i don't
know what squirrels mean squirrels means
p p means
money yeah they had money and
[Laughter]
they're just buying drinks and you know
these white men do rounds
oh yeah oh god yeah so when it came to
my round i was sweating yeah yeah yeah
sweating because i like i had pennies on
me because
and i was like because my parents left
me with nothing like these times i
remember like
people were talking like oh like did you
like do you have a job or did you rent
leave you any money or anything like
that and people were telling me like oh
yeah my dad gave me like 500 pounds just
to like see me over and stuff like that
my parents gave me nothing nothing and
they were putting money in my account
every week they put like 30 pound in my
account but that's nothing yeah
i can't survive off that i don't know
how i survived off it then but anyway
[ __ ] some [ __ ] didn't matter back then
yeah i was getting no grant no bursaries
nothing so i had this like measly or 30
pound
so when it came to my around i was like
[ __ ] and i think i just had enough money
to get one round and i had to basically
avoid them the rest of the night so i
didn't get to drink again
i didn't get to drink again and i was
too embarrassed to say you man i don't
want to do this rounds thing yeah
because i didn't know them i didn't know
anyone so i i didn't i was too
embarrassed to say like guys i don't
want to do this right
yeah yeah i'll buy my drinks you buy
your drinks yeah and um
but no so we did the rounds whatever i
had no money left didn't drink for the
rest of night
long story short it was a [ __ ] night um
it was one of those dress-up nights
okay but they their man loved that kind
of thing it wasn't for me
and um they texted me the next night
did you want to roll out again and i'm
thinking there we go these men are
burning holes in my pockets and i was
like all right bro
whatever so roll that again that's the
night i did the porn buffer in
okay went out with these men met them in
their apartment
uh they're flat or whatever and um we're
having free drinks
yeah one of the guys so the the flat of
the guy that we were in
um some short guy will never remember
his name
um obviously he was one of the two
cambridge donnie's
he was living with three black girls
so it was him three black girls and
probably some other guy so the three
black girls when we were drinking in the
kitchen the three black girls
came into the flat okay and they were
noisy
and then my man said
ah here come the [ __ ] golliwogs
then he turned immediate to me and was
like [ __ ] sorry
and i was like bro no problem in it
got up left is that cool no problem
just dipped because i think if i don't
dip i'm gonna swing this guy in his own
flat yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i was again the
[ __ ]
chest that you just put down to
automatically say here come the [ __ ]
gollywogs
and i was like wow
and i was more annoyed because i was
annoyed at myself yeah for classing them
as stereotypical cambridge white guys
makes sense the whole time before that
moment i was angry at myself
for stereotyping them as these typical
rich posh
white boys from cambridge and then this
guy confirmed it confirmed the whole
thing and i was like for [ __ ] sake
and at this point i knew no one yeah so
these were the only guys i'd even met
and then i remember thinking this is
gonna be the worst three four years of
my [ __ ] life
like this is gonna be the worst [ __ ]
three years or four
four years we were there right four
worst four years of my life like i was
so depressed after that day you have no
idea i wanted to come home fam
before i met you man you don't
understand what i was going through oh
[ __ ]
was the worst experience for me like and
it's annoying because
now that i've met you now it annoys me
more because i
now know that you all knew someone else
like aaron knew jay who was there jay
knew aaron who was there you know
yeah and these were the first two people
i'd met and they were
racist [ __ ] and i was just like
fam i wanted to go home i'm not gonna
lie i wanted to go home
i was like uni is not for me especially
knowing that i was the kind of guy that
does i don't like to go out
and meet people yeah anyway anyway i
don't like to just
talk to strangers and make friends you
know i mean i was just like [ __ ]
this bro you've never told me that story
i have not never
i don't really think about it to be
honest but yeah for that i wouldn't have
come into contact with anything to say
about that paunting that porn
yeah yeah yeah but that that was like
[ __ ] i hate uni [ __ ] i hate it here and
i was like two weeks in
that was less than that was a weekend
before we started like yeah before
i say would have been only a week yeah
and then yeah it just got worse not not
worse from there
but up to the point literally probably
up to five minutes
before meeting you
it wasn't i was ready to go home because
obviously from then that happened i
didn't speak to anyone else for the rest
of the week
only then i found out from jess where
our
lectures even were being held so if i
did she didn't tell me that i would have
[ __ ] up the whole team
and then i would have if i would have
missed the first lecture i would have
wanted to go home oh right
categorically the first lecture stems
your whole year
because it shows you where everything is
where to go bro it stems your whole year
because i know if i miss that one i
can't miss that next time i go no one's
showing me [ __ ] no i'll show you
i wouldn't even be able to find the
classroom you'll be able to find the
class where they're showing manchester
anyway
bro it was it was a nightmare
i've been to when i met you man and like
i said to you before the story that i
told you was when i say i walked in the
room and i only knew jess
yes yes you and remember talking
already at the yeah and i remember
looking in there and just from an
immediate picture
everyone already knows everyone already
knew everyone from where i was standing
no one in there didn't know someone and
obviously that's
a stupid way to think about it because
obviously no one knew no one from just
experience
walking in because i walked in late like
i said i was like one of the last ones
to walk in
everyone's chatting dems and [ __ ]
saucy excuses
they've known each other couple years
are chatting and you're remember
chatting so that's the quick
thing that i can see or lecturers
talking at the front and i'm just like
[ __ ] sake why do i feel like everyone
was already boys before we got here
fam it was the worst the first week of
uni was the one of the worst weeks i've
ever had in my entire life
wow one of the worst weeks i've ever had
in my entire life
i've never felt like more of a social
outcast
and it was sucked the fact that like
with these cambridge guys
i already didn't feel i already didn't
feel comfortable with them yeah because
we our upbringers were different and we
knew that from the offset jump
yeah and i was trying my best to tailor
my personality to fit in with them
which is not something i didn't do yeah
i know but i had no other option yeah so
i'm already
i'm already pushing my white side as far
as it will stretch yeah
and the fact that i'm actually trying to
act more like them so they can accept me
and then my man's being racist
in front of me i was just like give me a
[ __ ] break
i wasn't even angry at him i was just
like give me a [ __ ] break
like i already feel like an outcast as
it is not knowing anyone here
and now the people that i am trying to
get to know don't even like me
oh that's tough bro it was a tough week
oh you've never told me that it was a
tough
week it's tough it was a tough the
podcast was taking a dark turn it was a
tough week
but we got over it it
it's crazy because obviously i know you
so
people that are listening to the story
when you say like like when you say this
story
people might think oh but you're james
in it like
the people that don't know you that just
know you through the podcast
might think that's impossible you're
james like we know you through this
but this was 11 years ago this is when i
was a kid i was 18 years old it was 11
years ago
bro this was a lifetime ago a lifetime
ago it was a lifetime ago
i had no experience in anything [ __ ]
yeah g it sucked i never knew that it
sucked [ __ ] i [ __ ]
hated it and it made it worse the fact
that my girlfriend at the time like i
told you she was in leicester
yeah and she was living up leicester she
made friends like that
like everything everything that i wanted
from my first week at uni she got
and i was just like i remember the first
after we hadn't met so probably week two
i think probably be prep it was probably
because of that experience
that you didn't even want to entertain
like the freshers week thing
that much but i obviously didn't know
that but i
i i kind of suffer from what you suffer
in terms of that
of prior to working hospitality and
stuff um
not wanting to meet people not wanting
to be like oh let's go do this let's go
do this
let's go to and just start talking to
people i hate [ __ ] like that same hate
[ __ ] like that same i can
adapt to it more because what i do now
but back then hate to [ __ ] like that
that's the reason why i said oh
you said you were going to leicester to
see your thing and obviously my
girlfriend at the time would
went to leicester uni as well because
you all went to the moment yeah boom
i'm going with you i'm going with you
because i can't deal with any of this
yeah yeah yeah
deal with this pressure yeah yeah yeah
bro i've got to deal with this pressure
it was such a relief when you said that
as well and you were like let's go i was
just like
i couldn't do it and i remember the
first time when i told you we've said it
on podcast before
the day the day that i'd met you guys
yes
and then rem invited me to go play ball
yeah and you invited me to watch the man
you game yeah
yeah it needed to happen that way
because i never would have messaged you
guys first
to do something because of the week i
just had i never would have messaged no
one first contact i would have just seen
you
at lectures like you would have just
been i wouldn't have made an effort to
be a
your friend outside of lecture yeah in
my head i would like at least i've got
people to talk to at least
now yeah at least i've got people to sit
with lectures i never would have made
the effort to go and like be your friend
outside and i think also
you you underestimate the need
what i did anyway maybe not so much for
you because you'd been
to like boarding schools you've been to
nigeria you've been in situations where
you've had
to meet people yeah and you've had to be
the new guy yeah or you've had to be in
a new place yeah
before me i mean i lived in luton and i
moved to north so that's the only move
i've ever had
so prior to that moment i'd had the same
group of friends
pretty much all my life so in my head
like if i never had a job because
obviously before that moment i
had jobs and stuff so i've had people
that i would talk to
at work or talk to at college or
something like that
but no matter what happened i'd always
have my friends
yeah and they will always live five
minutes from me yeah yeah so no matter
if i couldn't find a friend of work
couldn't find a friend at college or
whatever i've still got my boys yeah
i think i forgot that when i moved to
coffin i think that's why it hit me so
hard
is that if i don't find friends a
lecturer if i don't find friends in my
flat or something like that
i have no one i have no one or nothing i
had no one to fall back on and i think
that's why
i remember when we first got that i was
pretty much the only one with that would
go home
every weekend no matter what i went home
all the time bro and i think that was
just routine because of how [ __ ] my
first
couple weeks were is that in my head i
had no reason to stay there i wanted to
get home as fast as possible
and i made sure every weekend i would
link all my boys because i
i hated it there bro i hated it there
the first couple weeks i [ __ ] hated
it i think there's no way i can last
four years here
there's no way and it was weird to me
because i'd never been in a situation
where i
where people didn't like me do you know
what i mean i know what you mean
like i know i usually make friends
easily easily and there's never been
a common interest just become an
interest yeah
there's no way i've come to a uni where
because i thought maybe everyone's like
these men
yeah maybe everyone is like because
they're the only guys i've met yeah
maybe they're all like it
and i was thinking if that's the case
i'm [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] and obviously i didn't know
there would be
like black rays and white waves and that
kind of stuff i didn't know there would
be that kind of situation
so the two nights out i had with them or
the night out or two i can't remember if
however many actually was
they were white waves yeah so i thought
but there were uni run raves as well
they were uni-run stuff and i was like i
didn't know
that there would be union run stuff
student-run stuff
um obviously then you've got the clubs
that actually incorp i wasn't thinking
about any of that i was just thinking
this is what i have to expect for the
and this is not my kind of night yeah
this is
not my kind of night right it was
dreadful sorry bro
i never knew that even though that's
such a lifetime ago i feel so bad
i don't even know why i feel bad right i
feel like
i'm very empathetic likes like i
resonate with what you just said and i
don't know why
because i've not been in that situation
before but it's
i can i can imagine what you would have
felt and it makes sense as to why you
went home every week
yes because i always used to wonder big
man you're going home too much
like let's have a weekend let's chill do
you know what i mean
obviously who am i to tell you that yeah
especially when we
when we actually live together i think
eve on even in third year you're still
going back quite a bit i was going back
quite a bit
part of my routine in the end but i was
like big man weekends are fun you know
we could have fun up here
bro i never i never ever ever
i that that scarred me wow
that scarred me i wish i could meet
these guys oh bro i wish i spun my man's
jaw
but at the same time i'm happy i didn't
yeah because it would have been it
wouldn't have been a bit
yeah and um it's funny as well because a
couple years after that
either the next year or the year after
that i actually saw my man walking down
the road
and such a plot twist
he was with a black brother and his
dress sense had changed
entirely um he looked like he was trying
to be so black
so hard justin bieber he literally
looked like justin bieber and he was
short and white like justin bieber
anyway and i looked it and i was just
like what are the [ __ ] odds
did you obviously recognize him did he
recognize you i don't think so
i don't think he even saw me in that
moment i just saw him walking down the
street i don't think he saw me
um but yeah that ugh that day sucked
it's ah i'm happy you didn't spin his
jaw now
purely because of what you just said
just then because if you had sponge
drawer he would have probably resented
mixed race black people for the rest of
his life 100 probably
but not probably not for the rest of his
life but like he wouldn't have even
bothered to entertain the idea of
chilling with
yeah black people or mixed race people
so the fact that
yes he knew he made a mistake saying
what he said in front of you and we're
saying
in general i got up and left like it
would have been like oh my god i'm not
in cambridge anymore i can't do nothing
because in cambridge i feel like
i'm assuming it's like a safe space
there are not that many black people in
cambridge
i don't need to go there to know that i
know that yeah i mean yeah okay
from the name itself i'm not going to
oxford i'm not going to encourage what
i'm looking for yeah yeah
so the fact that uni is such a
mixed cultural environment he had he had
to adapt as well
the same way you said you tried to adapt
to fit in with them he had to adapt to
fit into
everyone else yeah yeah yeah bro so the
fact that he kind of changed up his
appearance about
not necessarily as happy for him but i
felt like it's a better
it was a better response from him
than keeping the same old cambridge
state of mind yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i'm happy you did say that i'm happy
i'm happy i did it as [ __ ] as it was for
you
which i'm sorry for i'm happy you said
what you said about him walking down the
street with the black guy yeah
i wish it makes a huge difference to his
life yeah
the way he thinks about people and the
way he's what he says yeah do you
remember him
yeah yeah yeah i think that that day was
[ __ ] for me as well because like it made
me think like
at that point i'd never thought
well there you saw him again or the that
guy on the first
you don't actually think that people are
racist obviously not you don't you know
why
of course and i'm sure even though he
said that he doesn't think he's racist
and when you actually experience it and
you actually think
it's not the fact that he said it it's
the fact that that was his first
thing to think of like it's not like it
was natural to him it was natural
it comes out all the time it came out
yeah yeah that's the thing as well it's
not like he was looking for a derogatory
term
for their vernacular it was standard
heard that word in years
years bro i to the point that he said it
i'd never heard anyone
actually use it i knew it was a term but
i'd never heard anyone actually say it
because obviously black people don't say
that yeah and i was like
wow funny thing is those girls that you
live with would never know
would never have known that's
mind-blowing bro that's mine i had half
a mind to tell them
that was mind blowing i had half a
minute it would have scrapped him in the
kitchen oh they would have
run him down he would have scrapped
david in the kitchen
shanks and all bro and i'm hoping you
know what it is because obviously like
you said
i saw i i saw him with the black guy as
well i'm hoping
the year living with these black girls
is is what turned him
true obviously he's backing them out in
the first week i'm hoping after the
course of the year
he realizes he's realizing people yeah
yeah he realized that this is the way to
go
like i hope that's what happened i don't
know what i never know but oh it was
such a [ __ ] experience i can't explain
to you
how [ __ ] inexperienced it was i can
gauge it though like my heart
broke in my chest i could have cried
[ __ ] i could have cried because it was
just the tip of the iceberg
of like not the tip of the iceberg sorry
it was the cherry on top mm-hmm to the
point that sure it's a straw
that's what the word that's the animal
was like it was the straw
because it was like i already don't
really check for these guys
yeah and i know we're we're completely
different people
i'm surprised they even invited me out i
don't know if they just did it to be
polite or if they felt sorry for me
or i already had all these things in my
head
that i thought might be the reason why
they even invited me out and i was
thinking as well
it i'm not poor like i'm i've never been
poor
in uni i was poor but it's not like i
come from poverty do you know what i'm
yeah
my family always had loads of money yeah
but in that specific
situation my parents my parents hadn't
gone to uni like that
so they probably just didn't know what
to expect yeah and they didn't
understand that i might need money like
that do you know what i mean
so it's but i felt like i was poor yeah
and i felt like these men were rich like
it's weird like that it like i felt like
a yeah this little annoying thing it
loves you fam
it's direct i slapped myself this team
made me slap myself cuz
um like i felt like i was
i don't know i i felt feelings
that weren't even real
that i like i created my own barriers
between
these men like like the fact that
i don't know i started inventing
scenarios in my head like say i was a
poor black guy and they were rich white
guys
yeah okay and i was thinking in my head
i'm feeling these kind of way
my dad probably makes more money than
all of you man yeah
but the way i feel and the way that like
the elitist mentality that they're
producing
yeah just like money is not a thing for
them yeah but i don't know how much
money they have yeah and obviously
their version of money is not a thing is
spending 50 quid
at like a freshers thing where i did not
have any money on me
that doesn't mean i have no money
available yeah yeah yeah i just had no
money
and that that gollywood thing pushed me
over the edge
because i was like i was already feeling
inadequate to these men
based on things that i've made up in my
own head anyway but like the thing with
the night before with the not being able
to afford rounds
yeah the thing with these might be my
only option to jam with
the thing with like not enjoying the
night the thing with having to get
someone that i don't know to introduce
me to more people i don't know
when i didn't want any part of any of it
just to get along
that gollywood thing was the straw broth
it was the sledgehammer it wasn't even
the straw farm it was a straight
crack i was like ah i've never felt so
broke
the mandem are going to be so surprised
when i hear this like tobes jay and rem
because obviously i've never heard this
story oh yeah i don't think any of them
have
maybe aaron i can't remember obviously
me and aaron lived
with each other for a long time so maybe
he heard it but i don't remember telling
it
but yeah it was surprised when they
heard it it was whack wow
it was whack because i'm putting myself
in your shoes
and i'm like because obviously i know
comedy like when you're saying it i'm
envisioning it
and it's it's wow to me do you know what
i mean
you know what is as well is it speaks to
oh this is a much deeper pod than i ever
expected that's fine bro it's fine
anyway it speaks to what someone is like
when they're by themselves and not
someone like that's exactly like you
kind of thing
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah so what i mean in
terms of
like when you're alone like you know
how to explain it you know when we were
talking about yesterday
in terms of when we were talking about
the jeffrey epstein thing and then like
um
like my man will say get your clothes
off and they always the victim always
say oh you're freeze and like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're freezing
they're like they just end up taking
their clothes off and then
as a viewer you're like i would never do
that yeah you would never take it i
would never do that
like because they're by themselves
and they've got no one to go to they've
got nowhere to escape from
they act different to how they ever
thought they would act yeah
and that was how i acted in that moment
because i if i had either
even people if say for example if i had
if that situation happened
three weeks later yes when you knew us
when i knew you lot
because i knew i had the safety net of
you lot to go back to after that
i would have rocked him on the spot i
would have rocked him on the spot and
then i would have told the three yes
that he was racist to them but because i
at that moment i felt so
completely alone
[Music]
like my mentality completely changed
like i felt like i felt like the only
black because at that point i had not
met a single black person in coventry
i'd never been to coventry before that
so as far as i know it's the whitest
city in england i don't know
and you went the week before freshers
week and i went no i got there the day
freshers week
started okay so freshers week started
the week before lectures in it yes
i got there the dates like so the
saturday it started i think it ran
saturday to
the next sunday maybe okay and i got
there the first saturday
okay um and this probably happened on
the monday or tuesday
okay so i'd only been there a few days
um
but yeah because i i felt
i'm probably the only black guy in the
sea i've only been here a few days i've
not even seen another black person i
don't think yeah
and um because i felt in that moment
completely alone
my reaction to the situation was
completely
unorthodox yeah because it's like how
you'd find yourself
i always think you know when you see
people have a fight yeah
i always think would that happen if
there was just the two it was just one
on one
if there was no one else you spoke about
this before you said that if
you had to fight someone that was
one-on-one someone would have to kill
you'd have to kill one of them how does
it stop how does it end
because someone would have to kill
someone for it to stop yeah like it's
like
so the likelihood is the fight would
never take place
like in order for two people to get
angry enough to have a fist fight
when they're the only two people in the
surrounding area like no one is and
no one's gonna hear them shout no one's
gonna hear them scream no one is there
no one's back in one nose back in the
other
the like in my head like a scenario like
that happening
cooler heads would always prevail yeah i
don't ever see a fight happening like
that
do you know what i mean you'd have to be
[ __ ] livid
and that's how like it was in that
situation for me
in that like because i know i'm
completely alone
if i scrap this guy first of all i'm
probably gonna have to scrap his boys as
well yeah
and also who do i have to go back to
after this i'm going back to my empty
room
yeah obviously i went back to my room
anyway but it's just like
my reaction was so completely different
because i just thought it's a losing
battle
do you know what i mean it's a
completely lost battle if i do anything
about it
because i've got no one here like the
closest person who can back me
is 50 miles away back in north
like there's i've got no one here so i
was just fam
i felt completely defeated completely
defeated and deflated
[ __ ] because i was just like
and i think half of me didn't even want
to kick up enough us to leave
it took a lot of energy for me to even
leave 99 of my brain
just wanted to pretend i didn't hear
happen
yeah and just get on with my night and
then not text my man tomorrow yeah
that's what i wanted to do that's what
my entire mind was like because i felt
so defeated
i almost just wanted to pretend i never
heard it and be like
have this fake night and then have this
fake night and then never speak to him
again yeah because that will be the
easiest option to deal with right now
so it took a lot of my energy to be like
[ __ ] this
and then just go yeah and i remember
walking out the door
like my body was hot like of like
is one of them gonna shout me back and
they're going to try to beat me about it
are they going to ask me questions are
they going to like also when the my man
said it was the other brother there as
well
all of them were there so the yats were
walking in the hallway so they couldn't
hear it
but it was me the other game was done
and i think another don that i met that
day
yeah so i was just like yeah so it
wasn't just me and this boy
it was me and two other white guys no
three other white guys because it was
the bread that said it
the other the other bread the other
games around some other random yeah
it was whack it was dead fam
completely and utterly dead that's such
a shame
that's such a shame yeah it wasn't the
best never mind
we move [ __ ] um
sorry bro it is what it is it is what it
is
but like i said i hope obviously the
time you said you saw him on road with
the black guy i hope like you said
either living with those black girls
change his perspective
or maybe your reaction was the initial
spark for the change because if you had
maybe do you know what i mean because if
you had stayed and acted as if
okay i didn't hear it but even though
you never spoke to them again which you
wouldn't have
if he had if you had ignored it he would
probably think i can still get away oh
yeah that's just behavior i said it to
one donny in his face
and he didn't do nothing so yeah like
that's his mentality is like
it's minor it's minor now even though
he's not speaking to me again but he's
not going to do anything about it
so the fact that you just got up and
left because obviously he's probably
he 100 has never said that in front of a
black mixed race person in his entire
life
he's only ever said he looked at me
after he said he looked like a single
ghost
he completely forgot i was there so he's
definitely never said that in front of
someone before
so it's it was a it was a slap in the
face and was a huge realization for him
so i'm happy you left because that was
the wake-up call he needed because i
think if you had sparked him
it would yes he would have probably
gotten the same reaction but because you
would hit him it would he would try to
fight you back
it wouldn't have been uh oh my god i
need to change my outlook on life
he would have been like i need to fight
you because i don't want to get beat up
yeah that's all it would have been
that's all it would have been rags so
that could have been the spark
let alone living with the other the
black girls and then maybe getting to
know them before maybe maybe maybe
who knows maybe maybe maybe maybe but
damn man
it was a long night because damn
it was a long [ __ ] night um and my
porn wasn't even buffered by the time i
got back obviously because i'd only been
i'd only gone like an hour i forgot
about
all of that i'd only be gone like an
hour my pawn was still sitting there
ah that's hilarious i made this what a
conclusion
what a conclusion i forgot about all of
that i've said this to you before
when you tell me story because i've
known you for 11 12 years now
when you told me stories i don't know
about you
it freaks me out yeah i know what you
mean it freaks me out i know what you
mean
that was a week before i met you yeah
yeah and that's a
huge thing for me knowing that you went
through that
you know what i mean that's huge for me
because it was live chat and it makes
sense as to why
because i always used to wonder why did
you always go home but it wasn't my
business to ask because you want to go
in big man you want to go home yeah
yeah yeah yeah but it makes sense now
i'm putting [ __ ] together and i'm
thinking
you have no one bro and it's funny
because i never knew you wondered why i
always go home i always wondered
because i'm thinking because i never
used to go back to london that never
only when
sometimes like during like half term or
whatever or when
maybe there was something popping off in
london or a birth or something i didn't
have the energy and the money to be
going home all the time yeah right
because you drove so it was easy for you
yeah yeah yeah and i was like nah
you're going him way too often bro way
too often big man chill for a saturday
let's go yeah
i'm thinking i regret it now because i i
think i missed
a lot you missed a lot i can't remember
what you missed yeah yeah i know for a
fact you missed there was definitely
a lot of [ __ ] i missed um yeah bro i
could have even secured myself a little
ting and cop i don't even know
but never mind it is what um but
[ __ ] yeah bro that's thinking about i
haven't thought about that in years
i haven't thought about that yes and i
remember when we
started to become closer friends with
manchet yes
there was one night she was chilling in
our in our flat
and i so badly wanted to say it
i so gladly wanted to bring it up i
actually didn't know how close she was
with these men
yes i didn't know if they were best
friends in that group
i know she knew them from back home but
i don't know how well she knew them
you know what i mean so like there was a
time we were getting into deep
conversations about [ __ ]
and then it was at the forefront of my
mind and i was just like i want to say
it so badly like do you know your
bedrooms are racist [ __ ] or at least
one of them is
like do you even know that because
clearly you're not because you're just
chilling with us and you're
uncomfortable
and you're lovely and you're paying and
all these things
like you're banging like magic's banging
banging banging understatement
banging as a person banging to look at
everything banging personally in looks
and i was like how are you bedrooms with
these man because that man
he's a [ __ ] he's actually a [ __ ] but
anyway i just
i never brought it up and i think that
time me not bringing it up
i think i literally just locked off in
my mind and i never thought about it
again
um yep it was [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] [ __ ] i was so happy once
i met you man because not only was
not even the fact of meeting you man but
once i've met you man
everything opened up and it was like
this is unique this is uni experience
and this is
what i've come from and can continue
here like this is
like this is what home is this is what
back home is like for me and i feel so
much better now home away from home kind
of yeah yeah yeah yeah what's even
maddening that obviously when we spoke
about the origin story
about the backstory of our stories
that's all that what we said in episode
27 original story that was the only
context that i've gotten
the week before was obviously when this
[ __ ] happened i was like yeah yeah yeah
now you're telling me this now i'm
thinking oh my days
oh like it's
even though it was one week it tailored
the rest of your your years ago you know
what i mean she did i didn't realize
that it did
but it did yeah and it's just like wow
if you hadn't if you had missed all of
fresher's week and just gotten
gotten there on like maybe like the day
before
and then come to the lecture you never
would experience that and you would have
met us the same way blah blah blah you
would have been cool do you know me yeah
exactly
oh it was long it was long cause
never mind um sorry bro it is what it is
that's alert it's not hilarious it's
crazy rather um i thought today
instead of a mother [ __ ] i've got
um kind of like it's all kind of
asshole-ish
okay it's it's like scenario thing so
i love it we've spoken about this
countless times yeah
um never on here but like it's an
important topic
okay what do you do when your
teenage or adult daughter comes to you
and says
my man cheated on me
bearing in mind what we know today and
how we
are today and the honesty that we live
by today and just the
understanding of the game when your
daughter's involved
what do you do when she comes to you and
says i don't know josh
cheated on me just cheated on me with
some [ __ ] slag
like i thought he loved me and all this
stuff
do you play koi like josh is a con
you can do better or do you actually
this is your daughter
do you have the conversation
that probably no dad has had the balls
to have with his daughter
since the beginning of time but every
dad has always known
that the game is the game is the game
how old is my daughter teenage it's up
to you she could be a teenager she could
be 25 like
not a teenager let's say early 20s
because teenager
is not the game do you know what i'm
saying like 15 year old guys aren't just
out here slinging dick
yeah unless they actually are [ __ ]
okay yeah
uh
that's very tough because it's like what
you said when i gave you this scenario
about
the 70 year old jim yeah and then she
comes back home with your daughter
and he said you want to lie through your
teeth but you don't want to lie to your
door
do you know what i mean like you said
something long there's like yeah yeah i
remember now yeah
and me saying
josh for example he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
isn't me lying because he is an [ __ ]
for doing that to my daughter he is
but it's not the complete truth because
the game is the game is the game
but i wanted my daughter i wouldn't want
my daughter to get played in the game
don't want your daughter to get played
in the game
you don't want her to be a chess piece
in the game never you wanted to be the
queen
exactly but
i wouldn't know how to explain to her
that in essence
josh is a piece of [ __ ] granted
but the real travesty is that he allowed
himself to get caught
that's why he's an [ __ ] and
the harsh reality is is that it's very
very likely that she's going to get
cheated on again
and again and again and
how you translate that to someone
without them
questioning the foundations of society
i don't know i'd i think i would have to
i don't think i would tell it the game i
don't think i would because it's like
when
you're when you're a kid your parents
give you
some some random grown-up advice that
you that you hear anything
shut the [ __ ] up but it's only until you
go through simon that you look back and
think oh [ __ ]
my dad said this five years ago or seven
years ago whatever
and it resonates with you because you've
been through it does that make sense
so i would much rather i would still say
josh is a [ __ ] or whatever
if i saw him i'd knock him out i'll
still say all that good chat the typical
dad chat i would say all that spiel
but i wouldn't i don't think i would be
the one to
introduce her to the gamers the game i
would
want someone of her age to be the one to
tell her that
like one of her boys or one of her girls
you know i mean because if it comes from
me
i just feel like she would think
i've been holding back to tell her this
all this time yeah it's like
santa claus ain't real exactly it's not
for me to it's like you've been lying to
me my whole life
you have to just figure that out you
just have to just figure that out
and it's just life the same way i didn't
realize the game was the game of the
game
until i realized the game was the game
was the game do you know what i mean
it's true
it's true i wouldn't want to give my
because
if i told if i tell my daughter that the
game is actually the game
it's just how the way you roll the dice
and blah blah she's always going to be
on the defensive for the rest of her
life she's never going to trust the guy
she's not going to ever again she's
never gonna open up to wanting to trust
a girl ever want to be
because she's not she doesn't want to
plan herself plan to get hurt
and that affected her would then affect
me 100 and i would be the cause of that
pain
you know what i mean you're right you're
right you're right you're right so what
half the legs it sounds
terrible but i'd have to let her
experience
life and then when it comes to a terms
where
she understands it through experience
and not me having to tell her
then i feel like she'll understand why i
didn't tell her even that
even without me telling her does that
make sense there's just some [ __ ] you
have to go through
without parents having to tell you or if
they do tell you
they'll tell you when it's very invalid
in your lifetime yeah but ten years down
the line it makes sense
and i don't want to do that oh god i
just it's hard it's tough that's a good
question
it's tough it's tough especially if
she's balling in my face my daughter's
balling on my face i'm stabbing everyone
i can't affirm that i couldn't i can't
find my dog over heartbreak
heartbreak real heartbreak i've been
through heartbreak bro
same so if if my daughter if i'm seeing
my daughter go through that
i don't think she to be fair i say same
i don't think i've ever gone through
anywhere near what you went through
i thought i did you know what i mean i
thought i did when i was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and a kid but i didn't i really didn't
because a week later i was over it
so i mean i was on to the next yeah and
that's just how my life has been pretty
much forever
yeah yeah i've never really there's
never really i've never had like mini
ones
yeah i've always had loads of mini
little breakups i thought oh [ __ ]
and i don't actually think the ones
where
i thought i was heartbroken was more
guilt than anything okay it makes sense
it makes a lot of sense because all the
ones that i've been heartbroken
actually it's actually i say all the
ones it was actually one or two
i don't know but all those times or both
those times even
it was because i got caught doing
something [ __ ] up and i'd hurt their
feelings yeah
and they'd locks me off yeah so it was
more guilt of what i felt
and i didn't want them to think that i'm
a piece of [ __ ] because i don't want to
think of myself as a piece of [ __ ]
but i got caught doing a piece of [ __ ]
thing and i couldn't live with myself
like that it was more the fact that i
couldn't live with myself
rather than i can't live without them
context because as soon as
me and them sorted it out i didn't care
anymore as soon as i allowed them as
soon as they could possibly see me in a
good light again
i was over it was it yeah i was over it
yeah yeah and um
yeah so i don't think i don't think i've
ever experienced heartbreak now that i'm
thinking about i don't think i've ever
experienced it
it's it's not the one i've seen what
you've read through family it's not the
one it's not the one
it's not the ones not the one [ __ ] it is
what is
the game is the game the game even
though that back then the game that
wasn't the game for me because i didn't
know what the game was back then i don't
think yeah i don't think i registered
the game back then
you didn't register the game definitely
because there was there was red light
screaming and i didn't want to tell you
and my daughter
you or my daughter exactly you were my
daughter you're my daughter and you was
you were giving me
telltale signs of the game as the game
is a game and i wanted somebody to tell
you bro
get out get out and yeah you were
blissfully unaware i don't want to get
into it but you were blissfully unaware
and i was just like
this is going to end in tragedy this is
going to end in tragedy i don't think
man acknowledges that game is game game
is getting
run and you didn't and i only realized
that you truly didn't
when it was too late yeah yeah and you
were crushed yeah and you were crushed
to such a degree that i was like
my stomach hurt yeah and i was like [ __ ]
i'm i'm sorry bro bro wait the
the way you feel just then is exactly
how i felt when you told me the stories
earlier about the [ __ ] thing exactly
the same settlement
exactly the same sentiment i felt like i
felt so sorry for you
even though but the difference is you
saw what i went through with this
heartbreaking yeah yeah yeah
i'm just hearing this story for the
first time yeah yeah yeah yeah and i was
crushed
i was crushed for you bro yeah bro
that's wrap see you guys next time
that's wrap that was a hearty episode i
hope you guys loved it